[Music]
one of the misconceptions about Russia
is that's always driven to become a
European power because we identify that
mentality with the reign of Tsar Peter
the Great
however if you look further back into
Russian history it has a long exposure
to Asian powers its skirmished of course
with the mongols and was sacked by the
mongols
it also skirmished with the ming dynasty
of china as well so there is really a
Eurasian history to Russia and today
Russia again identifies itself very much
as a Eurasian power it's not that Russia
necessarily understands Asia better
let's remember that in many ways they
are very much a junior partner to China
a much much junior partner if we go back
to the collapse of the Soviet Union in
the early 1990s Russia was considered a
transition economy but still with a lot
of potential but its population has
shrunk tremendously very few countries
have his rapid population decline
meanwhile it borders China the country
with the most people in the world and
its economy is countless times larger
than Russia's is at this point so it's
very much a junior partner it does have
to deal with Asia more and I think we
would benefit from understanding Russia
better if we understood it not just in
terms of its relations with the West but
rather also the fact that it is sending
as much or more time these days focused
on its relations to the east when
President Obama declared is pivot to
Asia in about the year 2014 the response
and the Kremlin was we already pivoted
to Asia because Russia has been
reorienting itself economically and even
strategically towards Asia especially
China for about 10 years now certainly
as it overlaps with the reign of
Vladimir Putin now because of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine and seizure of
Crimea the sanctions on Russia made them
that much more likely to tilt and turn
towards Asia but at the same time it
also has to do with Asia's economic rise
because whereas in the past Russia
aspired to be part of Europe and had
stronger trade relations with Europe
than with Asia especially Germany today
Russia's largest trading partner is
China now when it comes to foreign
investment Europeans still invest more
in
than Asians do but they're also it's
catching up but one thing is for sure
the further you look into the future
especially with the belt and road
initiative of transportation linkages
across all of your Asia most all of
which pass through Russia and originate
in East Asia there is no doubt that
Russia is very much Asian izing
[Music]